luke dominate here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and today we're doing
the longest road trip in the united
states
you guys ready for this yeah
[Music]
so
i
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
today
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
woof
bye
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
well guys i hope you enjoyed this video
if you guys want to see more crazy
travel videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning and check out our
travel adventure playlist we'll put a
link in the video description below if
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching